druks
on one hand America's war on them has
been a complete catastrophe but on the
other hand it did give us this photo of
Nancy Reagan sitting on mr. T's lap so
it wasn't a complete loss and by the way
I pity the fool that didn't think they
were gonna after that specifically
specifically we're going to talk about
opioids and if you're thinking hold on
didn't you do a show on this before yeah
we did one two and a half years ago but
tonight we're gonna do an update for a
couple of key reasons first the epidemic
is very much ongoing in 2017 opioid
overdoses killed more than 47,000
Americans and second since then we've
learned a lot more about many of the
companies involved if something's been
amazing for instance a criminal case
involving executive in the drunk maker
iNSYS on earth they rap video allegedly
made to motivate their sales force to go
out and sell a painkiller containing the
highly addictive drug fentanyl take a
look
[Music]
you like silent all beasts yes Beast but
but let's just stop for a moment there
to unpack the line if you're trying to
ball I'll substitute you like a xylitol
that is a reference to the key
ingredient in sugar-free gum it is
astonishingly almost impossibly lame it
is genuinely difficult to come up with a
rap that is languor than that and I'll
show you
splash rules everything around me Hank's
get the mermaid Daryl Daryl Hannah y'all
now if that like is that like yes it is
is it lamer than the interest video I
think it's hard for you to make that
case and that rap video was just the tip
of the iceberg in terms of new
information now coming out through
numerous court cases so tonight let's
pull a few of these new revelations
together and look at what we've learned
about how the first wave of the opioid
crisis began because it's a story of how
major companies acted wildly
irresponsibly skirted any meaningful
consequences and for the most part
avoided public scrutiny let's start with
drug distributors these are the big
three that the companies responsible for
getting drugs to pharmacies and
hospitals they're supposed to alert
authorities if they notice suspicious
orders of controlled substances but for
a sense of just how badly they failed to
do that look at Kermit West Virginia
named of course because it's where come
at the Frog lives with this secret
second family oh that's right
he's in a throuple with two salamanders
named Francois and Gary and they are
very very happy it was it was never you
Miss Piggy it was him the amount of
opioids sent to Kermit a town of just
400 people was utterly ridiculous this
undercover video of Kermit's main
pharmacy shows scores of people picking
up prescriptions inside and at the
drive-thru window more than three
million doses of hydrocodone were
ordered by a Kermit pharmacist James
Wooley in one year it's true three
million doses to a town of 400 people
that's around 7500 pills for every
resident in Kermit and just to be clear
we mean every resident in comets not
every resident in Kermit Kermit
kermin is a top I'll have you know not
that that is any of your business but
those sorts of figures clearly should
have caught the attention of
distributors in fact the largest one
McKesson alone shipped five million
doses of opioids to Kermit in just two
years and that's just one example of
mcKesson's reckless behavior and the
problem is at no point will they
effectively deterred in 2008 the DEA
alleged that McKesson had failed to
control its controlled substances
McKesson agreed to pay a thirteen
million dollar fine that's all without
admitting wrongdoing and also promised
to do better by implementing a
controlled substances monitoring program
but that program emphatically did not
work in fact a DEA official later wrote
their bad acts had continued and
escalated to a level of egregious 'no
seen before because of course they did
you can't put McKesson in charge of
monitoring McKesson if the Bears in your
zoo get out at night and start mauling
the other animals you don't deputize one
of the Bears to monitor the situation
and I know what you're thinking but John
I've already brought him a little
Sheriff's outfit to wear and I think he
looked great in it and yes of course he
would but at the end of the day bears
are gonna bear it's just in their nature
and again before you say well I've spent
quite a bit of money designing a
custom-made sheriff's badge just for him
don't you think the bear will recognize
the gravitas of that symbol and feel
compelled to grow and change his bear
ways in some way no I don't because
bears respect nothing they they think
the importance that we place on symbols
and status makes us weak they value
nothing but blood and strength and I
know what you're gonna say now is there
anything I can do the answer is of
course not because while you were
talking
sheriff bear more due to death you're
dead now goodbye why are we still
talking about this the point is McKesson
monitoring itself clearly did not work
because in 2017 they wound up agreeing
to another fine bigger this time a
hundred and fifty million dollars this
time which yes sounds like a lot until
you realize that that is less than one
1000th of their revenue for one year and
well well today McKesson says that
they've improved their monitoring
systems for realsies this time pinky
promise
and and they argue that they weren't the
ones setting the demand for opioids at
any point even the DEA agent in charge
of their case thought that their
settlement was absurd how do you settle
how do you say it's okay just here write
this check this time and close this
place for a little bit sign this piece
of paper how do you do that no put him
in jail he's right
put him in jail and obviously I'd watch
an entire show that he's just that guy
telling me where to put things
McKesson executives put them in jail
these carrots put them in soup this
group of corgis put them in tiny boots
they should be boots but that is the big
problem here for companies involved in
the opioid crisis finds just became the
cost of doing business and throughout
this crisis it has been difficult to
find any real accountability for the
people involved and there may be no more
frustrating example of that than Purdue
Pharma the manufacturer behind oxycontin
the drug that arguably kick-started this
crisis Purdue famously aggressively
marketed oxycontin to doctors as a less
addictive painkiller that could be used
to treat common conditions like back
aches and knee pain which was obviously
untrue would be like using cocaine for a
toothache which incidentally back in the
1800's people actually did what an idea
that was my tooth hurt this morning but
I took some medicine and now I'm really
psyched about 20 different
business ideas I'm gonna write a
screenplay
[Applause]
Purdue Purdue is owned by members of the
Sackler family collectively they're
worth an estimated 13 billion dollars
which has enabled them to proudly slap
their name on some truly impressive
monuments to other people's talent the
Sackler name is on parts of the Met the
Louvre the Museum of Natural History the
National Gallery in London the Royal
College of Art and Institute jail a
library Oxford and exactly crossing at
the Royal Botanic Gardens not bad for a
family whose very name sounds like a
Hamburglar
like villain that steals testicles no
the Sackler came in the middle of the
night and now my penis is shivering the
sackless love putting their names on
things although until very recently
they've been miraculously good at
keeping their name off the opioid crisis
but that is now changing with protests
like this in New York City this weekend
protesters flooded the Guggenheim Museum
they dropped fake prescription slips
from the upper walkway angry that the
museum takes big donations from the
Sackler family which has been accused of
engineering the opioid epidemic Wow I
know this isn't the point but just spare
a thought there for the Guggenheim
janitor who has to clean all that up
Dennis didn't take millions from the
pharmaceutical industry Dennis gets $15
an hour and maybe the occasional chance
to masturbate on a Cezanne no I don't
say it's a good janitor I just said you
should think about it the reason for
this change in public perception is a
dawning realization of just how deeply
some of the suckers were involved
because unlike most second-generation
heirs to a Family Fortunes some were
very hands-on Richard Sackler worked at
Purdue throughout the crisis serving as
president from 1999 to 2003 and served
on the board along with seven other
family members and now thanks to a
number of lawsuits filed by various
states we're getting glimpses of the
depth of Richards involvement
Massachusetts alleges that Richard
Sackler at one point demanded to be sent
into the field with sales reps on visits
to doctors in fact his micromanagement
was apparently so extreme that Purdue's
VP of Sales and Marketing wrote to the
CEO anything you can do to reduce the
direct contact of Richard into the
organization is appreciated and going by
some of his statements that
micromanagement was in service of a
pretty clear purpose according to newly
filed court documents when oxycontin was
first released
Richard Sackler Purdue's former
president and son of the company founder
is quoted saying at a company event that
the launch would be followed by a
blizzard of prescriptions amazingly the
full quote is actually worse he calls it
a blizzard of prescriptions that will
bury the competition and then goes on to
say the blizzard will be so deep dense
and white and look as a tagline for
frozen - that's pretty good but it's
troubling when applied to addictive
painkillers and Richard SACNAS
glib tone continued even as Purdue began
to see the consequences of the drugs
that they were pushing at the dawn of
the opioid epidemic when 59 deaths were
reported in a single state Purdue's
President wrote quote this is not too
bad could have been far worse Wow
that is both callous and also completely
beside the point because the phrase it
could have been worse can be applied to
literally anything in fact one of the
only things it cannot apply to is
Richard sackler statement regarding
those 59 deaths and I have to say I'm
just not sure the full horror of that
comment comes across it and when you
just hear a guy read it out on TV and
the problem is we have to use Clips like
that because there are no clips of
Richard Sackler he never does interviews
even that photo is one of only a small
handful we could find and think of how
remarkable that is in and of itself he's
an incredibly rich man and it's
genuinely easier to find multiple image
options of birds standing on Turtles or
babies that look like one is short and
that let's all agree those babies look a
lot like one is short and this this
invisibility feels deliberate and
whether it is or not it has definitely
been convenient for Richard Sackler
because it it's honestly hard to tell
the story of his time at Purdue without
any video there is only so long that
anyone will listen to someone at a desk
reading from court documents trust me I
know that I'm
painfully aware of that so tonight we've
actually done something unusual to help
you get the emotional impact of Richard
SACNAS actual words we've got an actor
to play him so so let's let's try that
last quote again Richard Sackler a news
article about oxycontin addiction says
it's caused 59 deaths in a single state
how do you respond that's not too bad it
could require worse that's right
we've got Michael Keaton because
when you're casting for a shadowy heir
to a vast fortune who doesn't like to be
in the limelight you go Batman a look
that helps a little bit right here let's
try another one
as evidence mounted that oxy was causing
widespread addiction sackler urged the
company to publicly blame those who were
addicted Michael King what did he
actually write we have to hammer on the
abusers in every way possible
they are the culprits and the problem
they are reckless criminals sackler
genuinely wrote that and not only does
that come off as malicious and
cold-hearted it also doesn't even make
any sense
he's furious at the people who are part
of the problem but the people he's angry
at helps make him incredibly rich you
don't see Adam Levine releasing a song
condemning horny middle-aged women
because that would be hypocritical who
do you think made you who you are Adam
it's you're just dangerous enough for
suburban moms to masturbate to energy
that got you where you are today show
some respect to your base son now now
for legal reasons I have to tell you the
sack listen Purdue insist the family
didn't cause the opioid crisis and
vigorously deny the claims in the
lawsuits that we've mentioned saying
that Richard sackless comments have been
taken out of context with quotes
cherry-picked from among tens of
millions of other emails and business
documents but two things about that
because first whenever they've added
context it hasn't really helped much for
instance their explanation for sackless
saying the news of 59 deaths was not too
bad was that he was merely commenting
about the nature of recent press
coverage which is not better in any
meaningful way whatsoever as for that
Blizzard of prescriptions line they've
claimed the full context for that is
that his remarks were an allusion to his
delayed arrival at that event due to the
well-known blizzard of 1996 which again
in no way exonerate him oh hey guys it's
not like Richard was recklessly and
callously anticipating oxycontin's
popularity while it was sunny out it was
snowing hello and the thing is for a
family that complaints about a lack of
context they are thought tirelessly to
withhold it because time and time again
they've settled cases on the condition
that evidence will be sealed and
unavailable to the public in fact a few
years back Purdue settled a lawsuit with
Kentucky on the condition that the state
AG destroyed
17 million pages of documents 17 million
pages that's an actual Blizzard of
context that they did not want anyone to
see and you can kind of see why because
just the glimpses of information that
we've seen recently resulted in that
Guggenheim protest which in turn led to
the museum deciding to stop taking
funding from the sackless and the
Guggenheim is not the only institution
that's cutting ties the Sackler xand
London's National Portrait Gallery have
mutually agreed to call off a planned
1.3 million dollar donation it's true
the National Portrait Gallery bailed on
the stackless too and I know that as
punishments go getting to keep 1.3
million dollars doesn't sound all that
bad but keep in mind that these
people have infinite money and seem to
enjoy nothing more than using it to
purchase social status so not getting to
put their name on things maybe a real
punishment to them but I would argue
that that
only be half of it the other half is
having to put their name on the opioid
crisis that they fought so hard to
distance themselves from and that public
accounting is starting to become
possible despite the fact the Richard
Sackler has barely appeared in public
and there's actually a tantalizing
development here because a few weeks ago
the transcript of a video deposition
that Richard Sackler gave in that
Kentucky case the case remember we're 17
million documents were destroyed least
to ProPublica and stat news this is it
right here
this is the thing that Purdue really did
not want anyone to see and there is some
damning stuff in here the really
effective thing would be to see the
video of this deposition but Purdue is
fighting for Rochas lis hard to keep it
under seal which benefits them as you've
seen tonight newscasters reading quotes
will only get you so far
but we have the deposition and you
should know Michael Keaton is not the
only actor we got to play Richard sacker
in fact we got multiple actors to read
parts of his deposition word-for-word
and who better to convey the arrogance
of an early exchange about SACNAS
involvement in Purdue than someone
responsible for playing one of the
greatest drug dealers in there in the
history of television on July 30th of
2014 were you a director of Purdue
Pharma Inc mmm not that I'm aware this
is an affidavit filed in the Southern
District of West Virginia and does that
appear to be your name that does and
it's dated July 30 2014 it says
declaration of dr. Richard S Sackler I
am a director of Purdue Pharma Inc the
General Partner of Purdue Pharma LP I've
held this position since 1990 that's
what it says them that's what it says
Wow Richard Sackler came off like a real
dick there right certainly more so than
if I just read that to you and since we
had Bryan Cranston we didn't stop there
because this deposition also contains an
excerpt of a speech that Sackler gave
when oxycontin was launched bragging
about how quickly Purdue got the FDA to
approve it so we had him go full Walter
why
on that one too this didn't just happen
it was a definitely coordinated planned
event that took dozens of workers years
of effort to succeed the most demanding
new drug approval package for any
analgesic product ever submitted didn't
languish at the agency unlike the years
that other filings linger at FDA this
product was approved in 11 months 14
days our previous best approval time for
other products was measured in years not
months
I felt that in my bones I look
sure we could have stopped there those
those two actors were already incredible
but then we remembered this is HBO and
if we want someone to read this out
of another email that Richard Sackler
wrote this one characterizing his
devotion to oxycontin we have access to
the cost of another iconic drug drama so
brace yourselves everyone because all
are coming to make oxycotin a huge
success
it is almost and I've dedicated my life
to it
indeed I look the only problem here is
all of these actors are pretty cool and
Richard Sackler decidedly is not and so
to embody the fact that he responded I
don't know more than a hundred times
during his deposition
we asked Richard kind to read just a
selection of them how much money has
Purdue Frederick or Purdue farmer made
off the sale of I suppose I don't know
you know how much the sacral family is
made off the sale of oxy time I don't
know who's Lydia Johnson I don't know I
don't know I don't know I don't know how
many produ entities are there I don't
know
pretty effective right look Richard
Sackler might say hey that's not fair
I didn't sound like that but we don't
know if he sounded like that if we can't
see the tape which is why he should
absolutely allow it to be released but
if he doesn't we can only imagine what
was going on during his deposition for
instance maybe he was sloppily eating a
turkey sandwich during this actual
exchange about oxycontin addiction
have you made any effort or as we sit
here today do you know how many patients
who took oxycontin in Kentucky became
dependent or addicted no do you believe
that an appropriate number of patients
or an excessive number of patients who
took oxycontin in Kentucky became
addicted or dependent No do you know or
has Purdue made any effort to ascertain
how many people who were started on
oxycontin wound up becoming dependent
and moving on to heroin at some point no
why would he eat a sandwich during such
a serious deposition I mean yes maybe he
didn't but it would be so easy for
Richard Sackler to prove that he didn't
the point is until he does that we've
uploaded a bunch of videos of four
different Richard SACNAS reading
extracts from his emails and deposition
to sackler Gallery com
which I'm sure they'll enjoy they love
having their names
we've all something to various state
lawsuits at the site so you can read
them yourself the point here is Richard
sackless deposition should not be
something that Purdue gets to bury like
it's buried so many other things over
the years so please go to the website
and watch and use the clips as you see
fit
[Applause]
context
[Music]
[Applause]